Les bestioles mystérieuses
de la France.
Qui sont-elles ?
Pourquoi le cerveau
a besoin d'avoir peur d'elles ?
Quelles histoires se cachent
derrière tous ces monstres ?
Légendes, contes, réalité...
Ou alors juste tonton Michel
qui a fait une blague.
Et juste, ça a mal tourné
et du coup on y a tous cru.
- Comment tu sais qu'il s'appelle
Michel mon tonton ?
- Je sais tout de toi...
C'était le cri de la bête ?
On part du 17ème siècle,
jusqu'à aujourd'hui
pour voir les histoires
des six bêtes et créatures,
qui ont fait le plus flipper
les français à travers le temps.
Loïc...
Dis le !
- Générique !
- Yeah !
L'une des premières bestioles
mystérieuses à être répertoriée en France
est la bête du Cinglais,
qu'on appelle aussi la bête de Caen.
- De quand ?
- De maintenant.
Je savais que t'allais réagir à ça.
C'était sûr !
Elle apparaît pour la première fois
dans la forêt de Cinglais, le 10 mars 1632.
Genre, on a vraiment le jour,
on a presque l'heure.
Cinglais est à quelques kilomètres
au sud de Caen.
Et à partir de cette date là,
une quinzaine de personnes
se font dévorer en moins d'un mois.
Et là on se dit tiens Michel,
il se passe quelque chose je crois.
- Tu parles de mon Oncle ?
- Toujours.
Les habitants du village ne parlent
que de ça, ils comprennent pas trop.
et ils se réfugient un peu
dans les croyances
en imaginant que c'est un démon
ou un maléfice
qui a été lancé sur tout le village,
pour les punir de quelque chose.
Au mois de juin
de l'année suivante,
on dénombre une trentaine
de nouvelles victimes.
Donc la bête se nourrit un peu trop
au point de vue des habitants
qui flippent un peu quand même,
parce que rappelons le,
ils se demandent toujours
s'il s'agit vraiment d'un animal
ou d'une force maléfique
qui s'abat sur eux.
L'ordre est alors donné de rameuter
cinq à six mille personnes
pour organiser genre
une immense battue.
Ils réussissent à rassembler
environ 3000 personnes
qui ratissent toute la forêt
avec un seul objectif :
On trouve la bête et on la fume !
- Attends, mais ils vont
la rouler avant ?
- C'est à dire ?
- Bah pour la fumer.
- Pour la fumer...
- Eh ouais !
Par rapport à la Ganja !
- Et là et c'est ça qui est surprenant,
c'est exactement ce qui se passe.
Trois jours plus tard
avec un coup d'arquebuse,
la bête du Cinglais est tuée.
Donc elle existait vraiment.
En gros, elle a été décrite
comme étant un grand dogue,
une sorte de loup
un peu plus long, plus roux.
La queue pointue et la croupe
plus large que d'habitude.
La bête était apparemment
hyper agile et hyper rapide.
Donc rien à voir
avec ton oncle Michel.
La bête de Benais est l'une des plus
meurtrières de l'histoire de France,
apparaît 60 ans après celle de Caen.
Et un siècle avant la célèbre
bête du Gévaudan
qu'on évoquera après
tout à l'heure.
Elle apparaît pour la première fois
en Touraine au mois de février 1693.
C'est fou à chaque fois d'avoir
les dates comme ça des récits.
Tu sais, parce qu'il n'y avait pas
internet à l'époque.
- On notait dans un petit clavier...
- Un petit clavier ?
Un petit clavier ?!
- Un petit carnet !
- Un petit carnet,
des gens notaient
dans un petit carnet...
Non mais c'est fou.
C'est intéressant cette vidéo,
tu vas la liker toi ?
- Y'a grand moyen.
- C'est vrai, moi je vais m'abonner ici.
Donc en février 1693,
le 19 février précisément,
on retrouve le corps d'un petit garçon
de 9 ans, Pierre Boireau,
violemment déchiqueté
dans la commune de Saint-Patrice.
Et dans cette région
qui est très boisée,
où il y a plein de landes, etc.
Malheureusement,
une attaque de loup
ça choque personne,
ça passe un peu inaperçu.
Et là aussi ça aurait dû être le cas,
si cinq jours plus tard
il n'y avait pas
une nouvelle attaque
où on retrouve le corps en morceaux
de la jeune Antoinette, 7 ans.
Qui a été retrouvée par sa mère,
dans les landes du comte
Harebourg justement.
Au mois de mars
de la même année à Benais,
deux nouvelles victimes
sont à déplorer.
Mais cette fois,
c'est des adultes.
Les mois suivants,
c'est une jeune fille de 17 ans
qui tombe sous les crocs de la bête.
En juin, thomas Hue de...
Ah bah non mais c'est comme
la station de métro, c'est Miromesnil.
- Miromesnil.
Et bien voilà, lui,
Thomas Hue de Miromesnil,
intendant de la province de Touraine,
annonce qu'en quelques mois
il y a déjà eu plus de
70 personnes de tuées
et plus de 70 personnes
de blessées.
C'est vraiment énorme.
Il y a des témoins qui disent
qu'ils ont vu la créature.
Et au vu des détails
qui sont donnés par ces personnes,
la majorité des habitants se l'imaginent
comme une créature diabolique.
Et monsieur de Miromesnil
organise alors des battues lui aussi,
qui s'avèrent ce coup-ci inefficaces.
Et à la fin du mois
de novembre de 1693,
c'est un total de 160 habitants
supplémentaires que s'offre la bête
à Benais directement
et aux alentours.
ça commence à faire beaucoup !
Sans surprise, les habitants
ne vont plus du tout dans le bois,
ils ont peur d'être le prochain
déjeuner de la créature.
Et il y a les processions
qui se multiplient,
les prières pour espérer que
la créature diabolique disparaisse.
Et c'est ce qui va arriver.
Au mois d'août 1694,
les meurtres s'arrêtent aussi
rapidement qu'ils ont commencé.
Il y a le curé de Varennes qui annonce
que 250 personnes ont péri
sous les coups, les crocs,
les morsures, les griffures de la bête
en moins d'un an et demi.
Et personne n'a aujourd'hui
le fin mot de l'histoire
et peut définitivement dire qui étaient
le ou les auteurs de tous ces meurtres.
Est-ce que c'était vraiment
une bête ou pas ?
On ne sait pas.
Et du coup
on ne saura jamais à priori.
Troisième bête !
1731, sud d'Auxerre près du bois
de Trucy-Sur-Yonne.
Il y a un jeune garçon de 12 ans
qui travaillait avec sa mère.
Soudain, il y a un animal qui apparaît.
Qui se dit :
"Tiens je vais dévorer
ce jeune garçon".
La mère arrive à extirper
des crocs de la bestiole son fils.
Et il court un peu au village,
enfin son fils court pas tellement,
pour expliquer ce qui s'est passé.
Donc la maman porte son gamin,
court vers le village
pour essayer de le sauver.
Mais malheureusement
le garçon décède sur le chemin.
Il s'agit de la première victime
de la bête de Trucy
ou la bête de l'Auxerrois.
Suite à cette attaque,
il y en a encore plein d'autres.
Au point que cette affaire là arrive
jusqu'aux oreilles du roi Louis XV
qui va aller jusqu'à offrir
une prime aux courageux
qui arriveraient
à tuer cette bête là.
Donc on prend l'affaire
genre hyper au sérieux.
Donc toujours la même solution,
il y a des battues qui sont faites
et dans ces battues,
il y a de nombreux loups qui sont tués,
malgré le fait que la manière d'agir
de cette bête n'a rien à voir avec
la méthode de chasse d'un loup.
Mais malgré tout ça,
il y a toujours de jeunes enfants
qui sont les principales victimes
de la créature qui continue
d'être attaquée de manière régulière.
Il y a même une nourrice
qui s'est aventurée
à essayer de retirer un enfant, pareil,
de la gueule de la créature.
Et dans les textes qu'on a trouvés,
il est écrit qu'elle aurait
récupéré que ses pieds
donc ça commence à être
un petit peu chaud quand même.
ça fait cinq mois que ça dure
et il y a le curé de Val de Mercy
qui annonce qu'il y a
un total de 14 morts.
Fin 1734, les victimes atteignent
le nombre de 28.
A la même période,
deux loups sont abattus.
Et là, les horreurs cessent direct.
Mais on peut se dire aussi
que c'est un hasard.
C'est à dire que de toute manière,
ils faisaient pleins d'actions,
donc le moment où ça s'arrête,
c'est pas certain que la dernière action
qui a été menée soit celle qui a mis fin.
ça peut être aussi un espèce
de biais de causalité.
En tout cas, les habitants des villages
tentent de justifier les meurtres
en accusant
quoi qu'il arrive les loups.
Il y en a d'autres
qui parlent de loups-garous,
d'autres encore
qui parlent de démons.
Là aussi l'affaire
n'est pas tranchée.
La bête du Gévaudan,
alors elle a fait la une
de tous les magazines
et les espèces de gazettes
qu'il y avait à cette époque.
C'est la star des grosses bestioles
en France.
On lui a même consacré
plusieurs films.
Et elle a causé la mort
d'une centaine de personnes,
ce qui reste en dessous
de la bête de Benais par contre.
Celle-ci je vais vous la faire courte,
parce qu'elle mériterait à elle seule
un dossier de cinq pages
dans un magazine
tellement elle est passionnante.
Et ça tombe bien Michel,
c'est exactement ce qu'on a fait
dans le prochain numéro de Curiouz.
C'est l'histoire passionnante
d'une créature
qui va mobiliser les forces royales,
qui va alimenter les rumeurs,
les croyances.
La presse va publier des centaines
d'articles sur le sujet en quelques mois.
Et même les autres pays
vont en parler.
Et en même temps se moquer
des français qui n'arrivent pas à gérer ça.
Il y a l'église qui ira jusqu'à faire
une annonce officielle
dans laquelle elle affirme que la bête
est ici pour punir des pêchés.
En gros, ça nourrit tous
les fantasmes de l'époque.
Et je vous laisserai
découvrir directement ça
dans le prochain
numéro de Curiouz.
Pour en savoir plus,
vous avez les infos
à la fin de cette vidéo !
La bête du Veyreau.
En 1799, puisque on avance
dans le temps,
aux environs du village de Paliès,
qui est pas loin de Gévaudan
et du viaduc de Millau,
qui n'existait pas à l'époque Loïc.
- Pourquoi ?
- Parce qu'il avait pas été construit.
- D'accord !
- Il y a des enfants
qui jouent à côté d'un arbre,
ils aperçoivent un animal.
Et ils vont le décrire comme étant
plus mince qu'un loup,
à la tête et au museau
d'une sorte de gros lévriers.
Et qui a une incroyable agilité.
Les enfants se réfugient dans l'arbre,
mais la bête est assez rapide
pour prendre l'un d'eux,
Pierre-Jean qui est
alors âgé de 6 ans.
Des hommes
qui travaillaient pas loin
sur un chantier
ou je sais pas quoi,
rattrapent la créature parce qu'ils
entendent avec le bruit, etc.
Et à force de la courser,
de la faire peur et tout.
Ils l'obligent à lâcher son butin,
donc le jeune garçon.
Mais il est en très mauvais état
et ils arriveront à rien faire,
il a les boyaux à l'air,
c'est trop tard.
La bête apparaît dans les villages
en pleine journée.
Ce qui est différent des autres bestioles
qui attaquent souvent la nuit,
ou qui attaquent en forêt
loin de l'activité humaine.
Là, elle se montre hyper visible.
Elle s'attaque surtout
aux jeunes enfants,
à qui elle prend d'abord le foie
pour ensuite s'attaquer aux membres.
Et 15 jours plus tard,
la bête s'attaque à un autre enfant.
Le frère de l'enfant effrayé par la bête
qui s'est redressée devant lui,
va chercher de l'aide à Veyreau,
mais il est trop tard.
Et son frère est retrouvé mort.
Peu de temps après,
c'est une jeune fille qui se fait attaquer.
On remarque donc que la bête
ne s'attaque pas aux adultes.
Et plusieurs personnes ont eu
"la chance" de l'observer.
Et disent qu'elle ressemble
un peu à un chien,
mais que quand ils vont pour
la caresser celle-ci détalait.
Mais en gros,
ça n'attaquait pas l'adulte,
par contre elle les fuyait.
Donc il y avait un espèce de bail
de s'attaquer un peu aux proies faciles.
Le curé du village de Saint-André
a même juré avoir entendu son cri,
et dit que ça ressemble un peu
aux braiments d'un âne.
Je veux le braiment d'un âne
maintenant Loïc.
Et peut-être un que tu viens
de choper sur internet maintenant.
C'est vrai que ça se ressemblait.
- C'est assez similaire.
- Ouais pas mal.
Des braconniers
ont tenté de la chasser,
mais il y en a un qui a réussi
à lui tirer dessus.
Il a dit qu'elle s'était roulée au sol
et qu'elle était partie,
qu'elle avait déguerpi
à une vitesse hallucinante.
Après quelques mois,
la bête de Veyreau a disparu d'un coup.
Encore une fois,
il y a l'un des habitants
qui a émis l'hypothèse
que c'était peut-être une hyène.
Il y a le curé qui pensait que
c'était aussi peut-être un lynx.
Et au final c'était peut-être
un loup-cervier.
C'est un lynx du nord de l'Europe.
Bon d'autres qui pencheraient plus
pour l'hypothèse du loup-garou.
Mais faut quand même
se rappeler qu'à cette époque,
on connaît moins
toutes les espèces animalières
et tous les prédateurs
ou tous les charognards qui existent.
Et donc on pouvait aussi
construire facilement une légende
sur une bête
qu'on n'avait jamais vue.
Gros saut dans le temps
pour arriver en 1946.
C'est pas loin d'aujourd'hui
avec la bête du Cézallier
depuis le mois
de septembre vers Issoire.
Il y a une bête sanguinaire
qui se nourrit de chèvres,
de moutons, du bétail, etc.
Y compris d'ailleurs
des chiens, des taureaux,
n'importe quel animal qu'elle croise.
Nous sommes en Auvergne,
la guerre vient juste
de se terminer du coup.
Et la viande,
c'est un bien qui est très très rare.
Du coup,
ça pose un vrai problème
et les autorités prennent ça
vraiment à bras le corps.
Les forces de l'ordre actuellement
en sont même parfois obligées
de confisquer le bétail des agriculteurs
pour réussir à nourrir la population.
Alors il y a des écoliers
qui parlent d'un gros chien,
d'autres qui parlent d'un loup.
On parle aussi parfois d'un tigre
qui aurait d'énormes pattes.
Plus loin encore, c'est une hypothèse
de panthère dont il serait question.
Il y a plein de témoignages.
Mais ils sont si variés
que la chasse à l'ours
est déclarée
dans l'une des communes.
C'est vraiment on sait pas.
Le plus intéressant, c'est le témoignage
d'un agriculteur qui dit,
qu'il a abattu une bête
à la tête de fouine,
aux oreilles pointues à la queue
très longue et au pelage de panthère.
Il y a la presse qui reçoit
ce témoignage
et on conclu alors
qu'il pourrait s'agir d'une Genette.
C'est une sorte de carnassier africain
que vous voyez peut-être juste ici.
Parce qu'au final il l'a pas abattue,
il l'a juste blessée.
Et la tension est tellement forte,
qu'il y a un jour,
il y a deux jeunes
qui sont pris de panique
parce qu'il y a un animal qui s'approche
d'eux alors qu'ils se baladent.
Ils vont aller voir
les chasseurs du coin, ils disent :
"Il faut absolument tuer
cette grosse bête qui va nous tuer !".
Ils le tuent et c'était juste
leur propre chien en fait en réalité.
Donc on est pas safe
quand on est dehors.
Une autre hypothèse
qui est assez probable,
il y a certains qui pensent qu'en fait,
c'est un groupe de maquisards
qui sont toujours cachés et qui tuent
le bétail pour simplement se nourrir.
Mais l'histoire se termine
finalement en 1951,
lorsqu'on affirme
avoir tué cette bête.
Ce serait un grand loup, encore lui.
Et la bête de Cézallier
est restée au singulier,
mais son œuvre est en réalité
signée d'attaques de loups
pour la population de l'époque.
Ce serait exactement ça
qui s'est passé.
Comme d'habitude,
il y a d'autres hypothèses :
Ce serait une meute de chiens,
ou encore une lionne
échappée d'une ménagerie
qui était alors près de Limoges.
Je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
deux secondes
sur la relation
entre l'homme et le loup.
Il y a de nombreuses
autres créatures
qu'on évoque ailleurs
dans le prochain Curiouz.
Mais pourquoi le loup,
c'est l'animal qui se trouve
l'un des premiers cités
dans ce genre d'affaire
sanguinolente ?
Le loup est apparu
il y a environ 50 millions d'années.
Il fait partie de la famille
des canidés,
il chasse la plupart du temps
du petit gibier.
Et c'est un animal j'allais dire craintif,
c'est pas tellement craintif.
Mais il se méfie
et il approche pas facile.
Du coup, on pourrait s'étonner
que toutes ces bêtes
soient souvent comparées
à un animal
qui est plutôt farouche
face à l'homme.
Parce qu'à l'inverse,
on a une relation avec le loup.
Il y a même
des peintures préhistoriques
qui représentent des hommes
qui chassent à côté des loups.
On a trouvé des ossements de l'animal
dans des tombeaux humains,
dans des très vieux
tombeaux humains.
Donc la cohabitation semblait
se passer correctement,
jusqu'à ce qu'un jour,
l'homme se dise :
"Je vais élever des animaux
pour les manger".
Et à partir de là,
l'entente entre le loup et l'homme
devient un peu problématique.
Parce qu'en fait,
l'homme invente une nouvelle règle.
Il dit à son pote loup :
"Ces animaux sont à moi en fait.
Donc si tu les manges,
tu me voles.
Et tu dois le comprendre".
Mais c'est l'homme qui a imposé
cette règle, de posséder les choses.
Et du coup dès le début
du moyen-âge,
le loup devient synonyme
de danger et de cruauté
parce qu'il vole le bétail
et c'est très sanglant, etc, etc.
C'est le loup
qui décime les troupeaux
et les hommes se mettent à créer
et à raconter des récits un peu fous,
mêlant l'homme et le loup.
Et aujourd'hui encore,
le loup reste représenté
dans les contes et les histoires
pour enfants comme l'animal féroce
sanguinolant qui veulent le mal.
C'est un peu le bouc émissaire facile.
Et dans l'esprit des hommes,
le loup est donc celui qui vole
la nourriture par le sang.
Il est devenu l'ennemi numéro 1
des éleveurs de bétail qui a fini par devenir
celui que nous connaissons tous
comme le grand méchant loup.
Donc c'est pas si anormal que ça,
qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
une bête féroce qui attaque,
on se dit que ça doit être un loup.
Je vous le disais également
au début de la vidéo,
le nouveau numéro de mon magazine
mensuel Curiouz sort en décembre.
C'est le numéro 9, vous êtes déjà
plus de 10 000 à le recevoir tous les mois,
vos 52 pages dans votre boîte
aux lettres ou en version numérique.
Donc merci d'avoir suivi ce projet.
Si vous voulez ce magazine
de curiosité et de mentalisme,
l'abonnement est à partir de
1,65€ par mois frais de port inclus,
moins cher qu'un sub sur twitch.
Et plus intéressant qu'un Tepee,
puisque vous recevez durant un an,
10 magazines
chez vous directement.
Vous pourrez lire quelques pages
sur le site, c'est en description.
Et bien sûr vous pouvez
vous inscrire rapidement
via le lien aussi en description,
pour recevoir votre premier numéro
de votre abonnement
à partir du numéro de décembre,
qui traitera entre autres du dossier
de cinq pages sur les bestioles.
Je m'appelle toujours Fabien Olicard,
n'oubliez pas de vous abonner
à cette chaîne, c'est gratuit.
Activez la cloche pour ne pas
rater les prochaines vidéos.
Ici, je vous mets une vidéo
sur l'origine du mythe des vampires.
Et ici une vidéo
sur le trésor de la chouette d'or.
Pensez aussi à me suivre
sur Instagram, c'est celui-là.
Je publie plein de choses qui sont
complémentaires à mes vidéos.
Et j'espère que le prochain
numéro de Curiouz
vous plaira autant
que les précédents.
Prenez soin de vous,
à très bientôt,
Ciao !